[Musique]
Pascal Laurie on dit volontiers de la
France que c'est une monarchie
républicaine est-ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec cette expression
mon choix c'est une expression d'un
grand spécialiste du droit
constitutionnel donc quelqu'un de très
sérieux qui s'appelle dit Maurice
Duverger mais je serai assez d'accord à
partir du moment on assume le paradoxe
l'oxymore et qu'on explique c'est-à-dire
que fondamentalement nous sommes encore
aujourd'hui en Europe occidentale je
compare ce qui est comparable nos
voisins les Belges à luxembourgeois les
Allemands les Suisses évidemment etc ce
sont des
citoyens c'est ce sont des membres d'une
démocratie libérale comme chez nous mais
ils ont fait le choix historiquement
parlant parfois récents du régime
parlementaire et nous sommes encore un
régime présidentiel faut-il dire
semi-présidentiel en fait on dit
présidentielle ça ce sont effectivement
les spécialistes qui précisent mais
c'est quand même très frappant et lors
des élections présidentielles j'étais là
aussi très étonné qu'on revint pas
là-dessus en disant mais c'est très bien
nous sommes
tournés vers le président le président
le chef de l'État remarquez que tous nos
voisins ont fait un autre choix c'est le
chef du gouvernement qui est représente
exécutif alors justement est-ce que ça
veut pas dire qu'on a le culte du chef
en France
ce qui est certain c'est que nous avons
testé en tout cas je défends cette
théorie qui peut être un peu originale
la démocratie autoritaire moderne avec
Napoléon Bonaparte par exemple c'est
vraiment la France qui après la
Révolution ne sait pas contenter de
d'envisager des restaurations
monarchiques mais d'élaborer quelque
chose de très spécifique qui était
l'Empire on a retrouvé ensuite ça avec
le Second Empire madame de Stalle qui
avait l'oeil et qui n'aimait pas
tellement Napoléon c'était réciproque
avait dit c'est Robespierre à cheval
Reversi pierre achal cette démocratie
autoritaire c'est à dire vous êtes un
héritier des grandes réformes de la
Révolution et puis vous êtes un monarque
et ça c'est quand même une particularité
française à laquelle on est en très
attaché
même si on a quand même vécu la
Troisième République et la quatrième
d'ailleurs qui était des régimes
parlementaires la Troisième République a
fait a montré que elle était durable
puisqu'elle a duré quelques 70 ans ça
s'est mal terminé vous me direz
Quatrième République l'instabilité
gouvernemental certes mais des choses
ont été faites quand même les grandes
lois finalement sur lesquelles nous
vivons aujourd'hui de la du début de la
Troisième République elles ont été elles
ont été adoptées pendant un régime
parlementaire absolument et on s'en est
accommoder mais je ferai remarquer que à
chaque fois ces régimes succèdent à une
expérience autoritaire le Second Empire
qui était derrière en train de se
libéraliser mais enfin quand même qui
avait commencé par un coup d'État coup
d'État par un président élu au suffrage
universel oui Napoléon Bonaparte en 1848
évidemment la Quatrième République c'est
après l'expérience de Vichy mais à
l'inverse ça c'est vraiment un
contre-courant de ce qui s'est passé
dans les autres pays neuropbox
occidentale à ce moment-là au moins de
la guerre d'Algérie on a fait le chemin
inverse la Quatrième République a été
jugée incapable en fait de régler le
problème le général de Gaulle a été
rappelé rappelé c'est quand même très
intéressant il a mis autant de temps à
régler que la quatrième avait mis de
temps à ne pas la régler mais enfin
c'est vrai qu'il a réglé le problème et
il a imp un choix présidentiel qui sait
enraciné amplifié avec l'élection
suffrage universel qui existait pas au
début et j'ajouterai avec tous ces
dispositifs qui font que maintenant vous
avez une culture de la bipolarité
l'élection suffrage universelle avec les
deux candidats arrivés en tête au
premier tour déjà c'est très particulier
c'est le général de Gaulle qu'il vous
laisse et Michel debruck qu'il voulait
et d'autre part on a multiplié les
dispositifs faisant en sorte qu'il y ait
le plus possible une adéquation entre le
président ou le président élu et une
majorité parlementaire ce qui veut bien
dire qu'il y a pas la culture du
consensus dans notre pays en fait pas
toujours tout noir ou troublant si vous
me permettez l'exploitation en tous les
cas effectivement la troisième est un
peu la quatrième mais surtout la
troisième c'était rapproché de ça c'est
à dire que considérer ces fameux pays
voisins bien la coalition je ne dis pas
qu'elle est presque obligatoire mais
elle est naturelle chez nous c'est la
cohabitation qui de sur quoi est
considéré comme pas naturel il faut
vraiment que la cohabitation se termine
le plus tôt possible on voit là avec la
montée du populisme d'un populisme
d'ailleurs qui aussi bien de gauche que
de droite
on est un peuple qui conteste quand même
alors on a la culture du chef mais ce
chef-là dans le contexte oui alors moi
je distinguerais le populisme strict je
le mets toujours dans la droite extrême
je l'ai défini comme une droite radicale
dans un style de gauche radical
permettant de rallier un électeur à
gauche et ça aussi c'est très français
puisque c'est le général Boulanger qui a
vraiment le prince de la gauche lui hein
qui part de la gauche et qui a autour de
lui ça ne se dit pas assez dans son
état-major des monarchistes populaires
qui ont compris qu'il fallait que
le monarchisme évolue qui sont derrière
tout à fait d'accord avec le suffrage
universel en disant que le peuple est
saint et que ce sont les élites
bourgeoises voltairiennes des petites
villes de province qui faut une certaine
façon contrôler et puis par ailleurs des
communards il y a des gens d'extrême
gauche des socialistes autoritaires
planning socialiste autoritaire ancienne
et elle est déjà présente on les appelle
les blancs qui c'était une bonne partie
des blancs kystes soutiennent boulanger
donc non seulement on en a eu Napoléon
Bonaparte comme pour moi inventeur de la
démocratie autoritaire mais on avait eu
avec le général Boulanger ce qui est
d'après moi est l'inventeur du populisme
vous parlez de démocratie autoritaire on
est aujourd'hui dans un régime de
démocratie autoritaire en France non je
réserverai
alors effectivement je peux surprendre
par exemple la réussite Poutine alors on
peut me dire mais qu'est-ce que ça
démocratique ah mais je suis désolé dans
la définition de la démocratie il y a
pas un espace pour la liberté la
démocratie c'est la souveraineté du
peuple pourquoi est-ce que le peuple
serait libéral où est-ce qu'on a vu ça
non c'est une option c'est la démocratie
libérale je crois qu'on reste évidemment
une démocratie libérale et quand on va
vers l'Est de l'Europe évidemment
d'autres continents que l'Europe on voit
que la règle c'est plutôt la démocratie
autoritaire et moi j'avancerais même
l'hypothèse qu'il y a des démocratie
totalitaire la Chine ce n'est pas tout à
fait la Russie c'est une démocratie
totalitaire une démocratie totale il
faut d'une certaine façon sans arrêt
réserver démocratie à la souveraineté
populaire et donc se rendre compte que
ça englobe aujourd'hui si vous voulez
98% des régimes à la surface de la
planète sont fondées sur la Suède
souveraineté populaire on dirait ou sans
les deux pour cent l'Arabie Saoudite ça
c'est l'ancien régime rien que le nom
d'Arabie Saoudite le montre
mais l'Iran c'est une démocratie
totalitaire c'est une démocratie vous
lisez la Constitution iranienne ça ne
nous arrive pas tous les jours vous
voyez que c'est un raisonnement de
souveraineté populaire il y avait un
despote qui était le chat que le peuple
iranien renversé classique on va écouter
quelqu'un qui lui avait une idée de la
France très précise vous allez voir
puisque c'est le fondateur de la
Cinquième République voici ce qu'il
disait c'était entre les deux tours de
l'élection présidentielle de 1965 Michel
Droit lui dit mais vous savez les
Français sont pas très contents nous
vous parce qu'il parlez beaucoup de la
France peut vous parler pas beaucoup
d'eux et voilà ce qui répond je me fais
en effet de la France une certaine idée
je veux dire par là qu'à mon sens elle
est quelque chose
de très grand de très particulier
c'est du reste je le pense ressenti par
le monde entier
c'est vrai la France est une chose
à mes yeux
très considérable très valable et
elle doit avoir dans le monde quel qu'il
soit tout époque naturellement d'après
les circonstances elle doit avoir un
rôle à elle il faut que la France joue
son rôle c'est exact et pour qu'elle
joue son rôle il faut qu'elle soit la
France
les Français les Français ceux qui font
la France
c'est eux qui en sont responsables la
France est plus que les français du
moment
la France vient de loin la France vient
de loin elle n'est quand la France pour
vous
alors j'ai défini la nation comme un
peuple avec un petit peu qui devient le
peuple avec un grand-père donc le peuple
avec un petit P c'est une expérience
historique à chaque peuple futur nation
son expérience dans le cas de la France
qui frappe c'est la continuité par
rapport à d'autres peuples devenus
nation qui sont sans arrêt violentés par
l'histoire prenait la Pologne par
exemple donc il y a une part de
continuité une part d'unité même
d'unitarisme de volonté d'unité presque
forcée que j'explique par la conjonction
c'est pour aller vite du catholicisme
qui entraîne évidemment un type de
culture politique différent des pays
protestants où on le voit bien en ce
moment orthodoxe
religieuses à mon avis c'est capital
culture nationale et d'autre part une
continuité monarchique que Tocqueville
avait bien pointé en disant oui la
Révolution a eu lieu mais l'ancien
régime perdure très largement dans les
institutions qui postent révolutionnaire
donc ça ça nous donne quand même une
conscience de nous-mêmes que certains à
l'étranger considé comme un peu
excessive
je dirais qu'on a une façon de se
quereller qui remonte loin et qui
paradoxalement évidemment maintient une
unité nationale alors vous avez écrit un
livre extraordinaire et très érudit sur
la nation qui est sorti il y a pas très
longtemps d'ailleurs
la nation est précédée par l'État dans
notre pays
ah oui c'est absolument ça c'est évident
c'est absolument évident c'est même un
mode nation bah il y aurait eu un autre
type de nation parce que en revanche
vous avez d'autres modèles que celui-là
mais le modèle français un
contextablement c'est un modèle étatique
et du coup un modèle d'ailleurs le
catholicisme il contribue centraliste et
là aussi considérer les autres pays vous
prenez un pays comme la Suisse c'est la
France inversée c'est toutes les
caractéristiques de la France renversé
vous avez des aventures historiques qui
sont très différentes la nôtre est
définitivement l'étatique d'où un
rapport très complexe à l'état d'abord
une pensée libertaire assez virulente
par réaction et puis cette tendance à
gravée par les institutions dont on
parlait tout à l'heure de la Cinquième
République à critiquer assez violemment
le chef de l'État d'ailleurs il y a des
allusions déjà à l'époque du général de
Gaulle à cette situation et puis en même
temps à se tourner vers l'état vers
éventuellement le chef de l'État quand
ça va mal et
de ce point de vue d'ailleurs on est
tapé un pays assez révolutionnaire parce
que on aime les grands hommes on aime
avoir à notre tête des gens de de talent
et des gens qu'on révère mais finalement
on aime bien les dégommer aussi oui on
n'est pas le premier pays qui est coupé
la tête à son roi c'est les Anglais mais
les Anglais ne certaines façons ont tout
de suite fait une restauration le mot
restauration ça vient de l'Angleterre et
ils ont refondé l'Angleterre sur une
base de nouveau monarchique très très
vite et qui est toujours présente
aujourd'hui où on nous parlons ce sont
les institutions de la restauration
quelque part qui qui nous gouvernent
avec une victoire protestante et ça ça
change tout bien alors on est un peu
nostalgique quand même parce que on voit
bien aujourd'hui avec bon bah tous les
problèmes qui se posent à nous qui sont
des problèmes d'ailleurs qui se posent à
toutes les nations et à tous les pays il
y a quand même une espèce de nostalgie
tout le temps dire c'était mieux avant
alors on pense souvent d'ailleurs à la
période du général de Gaulle au 30
glorieuses est-ce que vous participez de
ce courant d'état d'esprit qui estiment
que ça va toujours de mal en pire
comme à mon avis la majorité des
historiens non parce que j'ai peut-être
excellent 13 ans de voir que quel que
soit les critères qu'on choisisse
franchement notre époque n'est pas
forcément en dessous des précédentes ce
qui est vrai c'est que alors là ça ne
concerne pas que la France toutes les
sociétés contemporaines sont des
sociétés en particulier occidentales
mais même à mon avis ça concerne les
autres pays de plus en plus
fondamentalement individualiste donc
d'une certaine façon je vais caricaturer
pour me faire comprendre sur le plan
politique la voie politique qui nous
convient il y a quand même eu une
douzaine de candidats au premier tour
des élections présidentielles et bien ça
n'empêche pas qu'il y ait une profonde
insatisfaction qui se manifeste de temps
à autre avec ou sans micro-trottoir ça
veut dire que la politique idéale c'est
celle que je mènerai moi-même le
président idéal ce serait moi-même vous
constaterez que c'est un peu difficile
il y a autant de présidents que français
comme il y a de sélectionnés mais nous
sommes des sociétés individualises de
masse les réseaux sociaux montrent bien
et quand parce que le poids de basculer
quand quand est-ce que c'était avec du
dualisme c'était avec la société de
consommation c'est avec c'est bien c'est
bien plus ancien je pense que l'individu
a toujours existé en revanche les les
fondements de l'individualisme c'est
plutôt le 18e et 19e siècle il y avait
d'ailleurs la Déclaration des droits de
la philosophie des Lumières qui apporte
ça d'une certaine façon mais c'est aussi
un certain type de société économiques
c'était aussi alors ce qu'on peut
appeler les technologies de la
communication aujourd'hui nous avons été
dans le génie de la communication qui
sont de plus en plus individualisante
c'est clair c'est clair et net comment
voulez-vous faire du commun avec ça oui
sans doute en période de crise un peu
triste et sans doute aussi aussi en se
donnant des objectifs qui réussiraient à
fédérer une majorité mais de toute façon
un peuple n'est jamais uni à 100%. il
est uni dans la pensée de ces
institutions politiques alors on a vécu
un épisode il y a pas très longtemps qui
s'appelle l'épisode des gilets jaunes
qui est peut-être pas complètement
terminé d'ailleurs on verra mais
finalement
c'est un peu un peu le triomphe de
l'individualisme là aussi il fallait
personne ne prennent le leadership de ce
mouvement et les revendications de ce
mouvement étaient pour le moins épars
c'est-à-dire il y en avait un peu pour
tout le monde quoi c'était c'était pas
du tout construit comme on a pu voir et
bien des moments révolutionnaires où
tout le monde ben voulait mettre à bas
par exemple les institutions c'était
même pas le cas là pour résumer je
dirais que les gilets jaunes c'est un
mouvement social qui n'a pas réussi à
devenir un mouvement politique pour les
raisons que vous dites et sans doute
pour d'autres mais alors c'est
l'occasion aussi de dire c'est français
cette France elle est vraiment anormale
au sens cette magique elle est hors des
normes est-ce qu'il y a eu un mouvement
de gilets jaunes ailleurs non je me
rappelle qu'à l'époque certains avaient
dit avaient dit oh ça commence à bouger
au Portugal mais non mais 68 aussi c'est
strictement français donc moi
j'interroge toutes les théories qui
disent bah les gilets jaunes c'est lié à
la périphérie etc mais les Belges ou les
Suisses ce sont des périphérie aussi
mais ils n'ont pas les mêmes
institutions politiques nous sommes un
pays d'institution rigide enfin c'est un
jeu de valeur disons assez
fondamentalement autoritaire nous sommes
un chêne entouré de roseaux quoi alors
faut pas qu'on s'étonne qu'on ait les
gilets jaunes et nos voisins n'ont pas
eu les gilets jaunes donc j'aimerais
bien qu'on me réponde à la question
pourquoi il y en a pas eu les voisins
alors il y a une chose qui est assez
singulière aussi en France et que
certains nous reprochent d'autres au
contraire disent que au contraire il
faut cultiver ça c'est le culte des
commémorations sur quel
vous qui êtes de l'Académie française
sur quel
fondement et bien se culte des
commémorations repose alors il y a un
héritage d'anciens régimes parce que
après tout une messe par exemple car ici
ce sont des commémorations mais le
siècle des Lumières y ajouter
l'invention du grand homme aux grands
hommes la patrie reconnaissante on a
inventé le Panthéon qui a été imité
ailleurs on s'échappe d'ailleurs sur qui
faut-il panthéoniser moi ce que je
constate d'ailleurs c'est positif à mes
yeux c'est que plus on s'échappe plus ça
prouve que le Panthéon on y croit c'est
à dire que ce grand bâtiment c'est
important c'est important là Josephine
Baker j'étais personnellement associé à
panthéonisation de Joséphine
c'était très bien vu évidemment la
clochait tellement de cases mais le fait
de s'échapper sur les commémorations
c'est effectivement typiquement français
et vous l'expliquez comment aussi parce
que en fait on s'aperçoit qu'on est mort
quelque chose tous les gens tous les
jours quasiment alors il y a quand même
ration est célébration j'ai fait partie
pendant plusieurs années d'août comité
des célébrations et puis un jour on nous
a dit un an
vous venez de mettre dans célébration
Céline alors on a dit écoutez on a
compris le message ça sera commémoration
et bien ça n'a pas suffi parce que
quelques années plus tard c'est Moras
qui a fait capoter ce Haut comité parce
que évidemment pour un historien
normalement constitué il faut commémorer
Moras il s'agit pas de célébrer vous
pouvez pas retirer les gens qui vous
gênent de cette mémoire nationale donc à
la fois on est très commémoratif mais on
aime bien susciter parfois même la
guerre civile en tous les cas des
polémiques à caractère qu'on narratif
est-ce l'histoire est trop souvent
l'otage en France des politiques
à partir du moment où on est un vieux
pays historien quelque part pour les ans
que vous avez dites et auxquelles j'ai
aussi répondu c'est pas très étonnant
c'est pas très étonnant moi ce qui me
frappe par exemple c'est que François
Mitterrand dont j'étais assez proche en
80 qu'est-ce qu'il fait à peine le
serment prononcé il monte au Panthéon
donc la gauche est très quand même
rative aussi c'était Giscard qui était
le moins commémoratif
et d'ailleurs on s'est un peu écharpé
sur une phrase je trouve quand même très
belle de marque bloc quand il écrit dans
les tranches des fêtes sous le coup de
la défaite un livre à chaud mais c'est
quand même un grand historien qui écrit
et puis un grand patriote qui va mourir
de ce patriotisme et il dit clairement
que je résume
ne comprendront jamais rien à l'histoire
de France ceux qui ne sont pas émus
symétriquement on va vous la montrer
cette fois cette phrase j'avais en
mémoire aussi il est deux catégories
français qui ne comprendront jamais
l'histoire de France ceux qui refusent
de vibrer au souvenir du sacre de Reims
ceux qui lisent sans émotion le récit de
la fête de la Fédération en 1790 donc le
14 juillet maintenant après la prise de
la Bastille ou la France ça veut dire
quoi d'ailleurs parce que ça cette
phrase c'est une phrase qui célèbre la
nation aussi et genre les gens réunis
quoi elle est signée d'un intellectuel
républicain tellement républicain qu'il
va s'engager jusqu'à la mort
patriotes incontestablement homme de
gauche pas d'extrême gauche mais de
gauche clairement compagnon de route du
Front populaire par exemple et d'origine
juive et tout ça ça n'empêche pas de
parler du sacre de Reims évidemment
parce que c'est il faut être empathique
à l'égard de la mémoire de cette nation
ça me paraît tout à fait normal
d'ailleurs par exemple on parle du
Panthéon à l'instant c'est très beau
qu'en ce moment ça avait été interrompu
par la pandémie rétabli les entrées
officielles dans la nationalité
française ait lieu pour l'île de France
je crois au Panthéon c'est à dire que
devenir français mais devenir américain
devenir allemand etc c'est
hériter de se passer aujourd'hui il y a
un mouvement qui s'appelle la cancel
culture qui consiste pour schématiser à
gommer à effacer tout ce qui n'est pas
politiquement correct qui relève de
l'esclavage qui relève de l'inégalité
homme-femme qui relève
de l'homophobie de tout ça est-ce qu'il
y a une menace en France que ce courant
qui vient des États-Unis et bien
déchire finalement notre réflexion
intellectuelle je sais pas s'il peut
déchirer mais il est de présent mais à
mon avis il sera de plus en plus présent
d'ailleurs dans l'ensemble de l'Occident
cependant il pose des problèmes de fond
ça ne me gêne pas qu'on distingue
justement on vient de le faire
commémoration et célébration donc un
Robert lit
grand sudiste célébré ça peut
aujourd'hui poser un vrai problème
déboulonner réellement ou symboliquement
cette absurde parce que c'est pas comme
ça qu'on règle ces problèmes avec le
passé d'autre part quand on voit la
liste des objets naturels c'est toujours
beaucoup plus complexe prenons par
exemple le critère de l'antisémitisme
Richard Wagner reste un grand
compositeur dans l'ordre musical
indépendamment pour moi en tant
qu'historien indépendamment de ce qu'il
a écrit sur les Juifs on peut aimer
Wagner pour sa musique pas parce qu'il
est antisémite et c'est tout le temps
comme ça vous avez un certain nombre de
discrédits alors c'est assez
individualiste paradoxalement le
mouvement wok vous vous focalisez sur
une individualité vous cherchez comme le
disait Barbery on cherche des poux dans
la crinière des lions vous cherchez des
poux des grands pots parfois ce sont de
vrais problèmes un intellectuaire pour
moi ça reste une vraie question quand on
est prétendument le grand philosophe de
sa génération quand on est au pied du
mur 1933 mais en revanche il y a un
mélange déjà par exemple Victor
schœutcher c'est un grand homme qui a
libéré incontestablement les Antilles et
on sait bien que la libération de
l'esclavage officiel ne résolvait pas
les problèmes on le voit bien en ce
moment et alors à ce moment-là vous
évacuez tout le monde je vous signale
que si c'est le critère c'est
l'esclavage toute la culture médiévale
toute la culture antique
chrétienne parce que du moyen-âge et
musulman disparaît bien sûr
c'est absurde parce que de toute façon
on aura un un retour du refoulé alors
parce qu'aujourd'hui on va je vais vous
demander de vous livrer un petit
questionnaire de Proust je veux dire si
la France c'était voici la France
c'était un paysage pour vous ça serait
quoi il se trouve que j'habite à
Chartres et je pense spontanément à la
cathédrale mais avec ce recul de la
Beauce parce qu'il faut savoir que comme
la cathédrale a été construite
effectivement ça Charles Péguy notamment
sur un oppidum des pop très chrétiennes
et bien la cathédrale se voit très loin
c'est presque un artiste et par ailleurs
bien entendu c'est une c'est une
cathédrale absolument impressionnante
très belle avec des vitraux
extraordinaires mais surtout il me
semble que c'est une bonne façon de
résumer y compris la mythologie peu
importe vous avez les mythes on en avait
tous besoin ce sont des dit que nous
nous racontons mais il y a des
mythologies wok il y a des mythologies
anarchistes là c'est la mythologie
nationale et un certain moment je
n'oublie pas que il y a eu Charles Péguy
dans ton seul rôle dans l'affaire
Dreyfus et le préfet de Chartres
s'appelait Jean Moulin en 1940 si
c'était une œuvre littéraire ça pourrait
être laquelle ce n'est peut-être pas
celle à laquelle on s'attend je
penserait spontanément à Jules et gym
oui sans doute parce que j'aime le film
de Truffaut Truffaut a un rapport très
particulier avec l'auteur du roman
initial qui s'appelle Henry Pierre Roche
et c'est un roman pour moi superbe c'est
un avis personnel mais au-delà le
rapport à la nation française d'abord
c'est un roman sur un dialogue
d'un Allemand et d'un Français qui sont
amoureux de la même femme
qui dans la réalité il faut le savoir
puisque c'est très largement
autobiographique et la mère de Stéphane
Hessel qui était un grand diplomate
français et le père de Stéphane Hessel
c'est Jules et Jim c'est rocher et et
rocher c'est c'est un de la médiation du
dialogue entre les cultures c'est un
homme qui est toujours en arrière de la
main il a terminé ce roman à plus de 70
ans vous imaginez donc il se réveille
écrivain puis une franchissait pas le
pas et quand il a appris la mort de
Jules là il a franchi le pas et puis
pour Truffaut ça a été un maître parce
que les deux anglaises elles continuent
super film qui te sort de Julie gymne
d'après rocher et l'homme qui aimait les
femmes de Truffaut souviens de Charles
Denner dans le film inspiré de la de la
vie de rocher mais lisez que les
téléspectateurs qui ne regardent et nous
écoutent Jul et Gilles et gym c'est
c'est une littérature claire presque
sèche à la limite qui va qui va droite
au but
faut-il dire que c'est typiquement
français faut se méfier un peu de ce
genre de considération mais pour moi oui
si c'était un tableau par exemple ça
serait quoi le oh la Liberté guidant le
peuple c'est peut-être pas de la Croix
de la croix c'est un grand tableau
magnifique un grand auteur pas
révolutionnaire lui-même que ça mais
entraîné par le mouvement de 1830 grand
écrivain aussi il faut le dire oui
absolument et ce qui est intéressant
c'est que c'est devenu une icône pensez
à ce qui s'est passé en 2015 au moment
des attentats de Charlie vous avez eu
l'extraordinaire dessin de planture en
première page on a le monde vous avez eu
deux grandes photographies de
manifestants avec des drapeaux
tricolores on ne voyait plus tellement
les drapeaux de tricolores dans les
grandes manifestations du côté de la
place de la République etc et vous
rappelez sur la façade de Beaubourg
c'est grandes photos qui avaient été
prises presque spontanément sous l'angle
de la croix
et si c'était une un personnage
historique alors ça serait lequel
on a déjà vu et entendu le général de
Gaulle j'aurais tendance à faire un pas
de côté d'autant plus que j'ai beaucoup
travaillé sur cet auteur parce que c'est
aussi un auteur justement c'est Léon
Blum parce que Léon Blum c'est à la fois
pour moi l'intellectuel qui franchit le
pas qui n'est pas le cas tous les
intellectuels pour devenir politique
homme politique mais surtout chef de
gouvernement il va jusqu'au bout il y a
pas tellement va de soi Vaval par
exemple oui mais ils sont pas si
nombreux les intellectuels souvent
et puis c'est effectivement quelqu'un
qui est attaché à des moments essentiels
de l'histoire de France l'affaire
Dreyfus sur laquelle il a écrit un
superbe texte le Front populaire et puis
je ne peux pas oublier que c'est aussi
typique d'un destin juif c'est-à-dire
quand même ces différentes générations
qui ont permis qu'un certain moment
comme par hasard au début de la
Troisième République tonton
et bien ils puissent par exemple être le
premier juif il faut le dire clairement
entrer au Conseil d'État donc devenir un
grand juriste devenir quelqu'un qui qui
va jouer un rôle important dans la
définition de la France normalien très
grand intellectuel critique littéraire
et voilà effectivement tous parcours il
écrira un livre aussi sur le mariage que
j'ai que j'ai édité réédité commenté et
qui est très intéressant tout à fait
d'actualité merci parce que merci pour
ce bel entretien merci beaucoup merci à
vous
[Musique]